after four long tense days we've reached
a historic moment in this election joe
biden
is president-elect america's democracy
is not guaranteed it is only as strong
as our willingness to fight for it
[Applause]
when i look back on biden's campaign i
think the single most
impressive thing he did were the biden
sanders task forces that followed the
primary cbs news projects the former
vice president beats senator bernie
sanders in florida
illinois and arizona biden now has more
than half of the 1991 delegates needed
to clinch the democratic nomination
my goal as a candidate for president is
to unify this party
and then to unify the nation he invited
all of these different players who had
been
harsh critics of the bibing campaign the
sunrise movement which is the the
youth-led climate movement
he invited the sunrise movement into the
task force they'd been incredibly
critical of biden they've given his
climate plan an app
you've had at least some hand in shaping
kind of forming joe biden's climate plan
joe biden's plan
will present a seismic shift in climate
policy at the federal level
than anything that we have seen in the
last 40 years alexandra ocasio-cortez
who had said in another country
her and biden wouldn't even be in the
same political party into the task force
and it worked
voting for joe biden is not about
whether you agree with him
it's a vote to let our democracy live
another day that's what this is about
it's so beautiful to see someone who
stood for oppression and the system
changed because of activism and just the
voice of young people
crying out but
there is no reason to think that because
joe biden won the election he'll be able
to govern
i think the likeliest outcome they're
going to have a joe biden
presidency and a mitch mcconnell senate
and that means that lots of things joe
biden wants to do are not going to
happen
i was looking at some data from a fox
news
analysis there's these questions
like how concerned about the effects of
climate change are you
and you're getting 46 vary 26
somewhat gun laws pathway to citizenship
changing to a government-run health care
plan it seems
clear from this data that what the
american people want
is not being translated to law and
policy and i'm wondering if you can give
some context as to why that is
those numbers don't in any way surprise
me we've seen numbers like that for a
very long time
as of right now joe biden holds a lead
of about 13
500 votes
the key thing to understand about the
modern republican party is
it is a party that routinely is not able
to win the most votes
at any level of the national system it
has lost a popular vote in seven of the
last presidential elections
it has gotten fewer votes in the last
three or four senate elections in a row
a party that wins power without winning
the most votes is going to turn against
democracy itself
many forced to wait for hours in part
because of new voting machines that were
either missing or not working
20 fewer polling places
than we had in 2016. this line of people
wraps around the block there's a line of
cars to curbside vote
people waited in line for two three four
hours just to cast a vote
right after the house attempted to pass
a bill that would have made
voting during a pandemic easier post
office to deliver ballots what trump
said
on fox and friends was they they had
things uh levels of voting that if you
ever agreed to it you'd never have a
republican elected in this country again
what i'm wondering is obviously there
are conservative parties
in other democratic systems that win
power all the time
in canada or great britain or australia
other um majoritarian democracies he's
wrong that the republican party would
never win power again what he's right
about is that his republican party would
never win power again
a party that is increasingly afraid of
what would happen to it if it was
exposed to full-on
actual democracy right you're saying if
they really had to compete for votes
that they would have to
begin to embrace some of those policies
as conservative parties in those
countries have done
yes thank you very much as we speak
donald trump is functionally engaged
in what we would understand in another
country as a coup attempt if you count
the
legal votes i easily win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to steal the election from us if our
goal is to defend the integrity of the
election
we'll not allow the corruption to steal
such an important election or any other
well we're interrupting this because
what the president of the united states
is saying
in large part is absolutely untrue
it's a very dangerous moment but even
beneath that
what you then end up having is when a
party wins power without winning votes
they will tend to use that
power to make it easier to win power
without winning votes all signs guys all
signs point to a runoff in georgia not
just one but two senate races here in
georgia what that means here is that
georgia could be at the center of the
political universe
through early next year january 5th is
when the runoff is
so those georgia runoffs they're really
really really important
record number of americans of all races
faiths religions
chose change over more of the same
if democrats win the senate and choose
to make democracy a priority
there's a lot they can actually do uh dc
and puerto rico should be offered
statehood that's
obvious things like automatic voter
registration
mail and balloting like we should just
make elections a lot simpler to
participate in
make sure people's voices are being
heard more clearly democracy
works and i want you to know that our
work is hard for those who voted against
me
as those who voted for me that's the job
that's the job
you